thanks for coming so this task is based
on joint works with Jem ding and Alan
sigh and you man Jong so this is the
same setting as for Alan's talk so I
hope you remember it all so just to
remind we we have a random regular
bipartite graph by protoid factor graph
so I'll denoted vfe where we are the
variables are for the clauses in ER the
edges that join between them so to
sample such a graph you put down the
clauses and you put down in the
variables so each one each class has
outgoing from it k edges each variable
has outgoing from addie ages and you
choose a random matching between the
uniformly at random from the set of all
matching I hope that the model is clear
and then the the size of VL denote by n
and the size of asses and and the the
class variable ratio is denoted alpha
which is M over N and it will since it's
a regular graph it's the same as d / k
so the number of edges that go between
them equal to n times here the same
and so if I write down here people can
see so I'll say that an assignment of 0
1 values to the variables is a valid by
coloring
gee it's a for every clause a in F so
for every a so the the K variables that
adjoins to so it joins to some k tupolev
variables so I'll denote a delta a to be
the tuple of variables that participate
in the clause so it's a valid by
coloring if for every age this the the
value of the variable assignments on
this k2 bull is is not all equal meaning
X Delta a is in 01 k minus all 0 or a 1
in other words you want to assign zeros
and ones to the variables such that no
no clause will be monochromatic and so
actually it's a little bit different
from the the model that Alan talked
about where each class sees the variable
plus a random coin flip so all of our
results are per model that he described
but I just will keep to this model oh
I'll denote this to be the set of all
valid by colorings
we're we're interested in the the
typical properties of this such as you
vary the the class to variable ratio
alpha and then the most basic question
that you can ask is what is the typical
value of the the total size of this set
so just to recall from from Alan's talk
you can easily calculate the expected
value so expected a number of solutions
so the total number of solutions is 2 to
the N and then you have em clauses and
each one is violated with the same
probability and all of the causes are
independent so this is the probability
that a single Clause is satisfied and
then you just raise it to the number of
clauses
so this is what's usually called the the
replica symmetric free energy it's just
that the exponent in the the first
moment and it's a linearly decreasing
function of alpha and then the
conjecture from statistical physics
so I actually don't know how to
pronounce all this name so i'll just
write them
and also so this is the maybe the most
relevant paper and there's also some
earlier work that is also related
these people are incredibly well
concentrated in this room tragedy is I
couldn't bribe any of them to give this
talk so so anyway so that the conjecture
from from this collection of work is
that for for up to a condensation
threshold alpha Khan said is supposed to
be well concentrated around its
expectation and then for alpha con
there should be an interval of alpha
going between some condensation
threshold and some satisfiability
specials such that said concentrates
around a different value this the one
RSV rate and this is exponentially
smaller compared with the expectation of
this and finally for we're also larger
than alpha set
in in previous work so in in joint work
with gending and Allen fly we we found
the existence and value for for the
Natalie Cole fat version of this model
for four large k and then in a work by a
vast Cody Oakland harwich grassman and
villain chick 2014 they determine the
existence and value of alpha con not for
this model for actually a much more
interesting model so they determined it
for coloring the erdos-renyi sports
ground and this is a I think for a
number of colors larger than some Q
knobs and then most of this talk is
related to joint work with Allen spy and
even run which is the existence and
value of the free energy
that this limit is taken in probability
so so maybe just to recall what what is
a replica symmetry versus replica
symmetry breaking so from from our
perspective it's it's a way to classify
stochastic processes so consider new to
be the uniform measure on the the
solution space of the the graph and then
we'll say that new exhibits replica
symmetry or replica symmetry breaking
according to the following criteria so
so if you sample X from New it's it just
means that you sample a random by
coloring of your instance and then you
can view this as a binary valued
stochastic process
and it's indexed by the the variables of
the graph so we'll say that new is
replica symmetric if whenever whenever
you take two variables that are far
apart with respect to the grass distance
if two variables are far apart then you
have a correlation de queso X of U and X
of V are approximately independent and
replica symmetry breaking is if that
doesn't hold so meaning that new has
long-range correlations
okay and then just to recall how how can
long-range correlations arise in the
model so they arise in the the
condensation regime so so recall that a
typical typical solution X it has some
positive density of free variables
so it has a positive fraction of
variables that you can freely change
their value without violating any of the
causes that they belong to so in other
words by changing the various values a
typical X it has to belong into inside
what we'll call a cluster meaning some
fairly large connected component of the
solution space so the connected
component will be a size like 2 to the n
epsilon for some small okay so then so
conjectural a there exists some Sigma of
s which also implicitly depends on alpha
such that the number of clusters of size
exponential and s concentrates around
its mean value
and the mean equal financial of n Sigma
so in particular if you want to
calculate the expected value of said
it's the you group the solutions
according to the size of the cluster to
which they belong so you get exponential
event and like Alan was mentioning this
is dominated by that point where Sigma
has 12-1 so in the condensation regime
what you have is the following pictures
so this is s this is Sigma and the the
curve looks something like this and this
is the point where you have slope minus
1 so we'll call this s 1 so this gives
the main contribution to the first
moment but it's for a size of the
cluster which since the value here is
negative it's exponentially unlikely to
okay it's just that the site is so large
that it dominates the first moment and
the sizes of costumes that can actually
typically occur are only up to here so
they go between here and here and i'll
call this S sub Max and if you look at
the the trade-off between s and Sigma
vests among the ones that can typically
occur the the one that maximizes this
trade-off is exactly the maximum so that
means that the the typical number of
solutions is going to be dominated
exactly by this size of clusters and and
since this size of clusters corresponds
to a value of Sigma which is 0 it
suggests that you have a bounded number
of clusters that take most of the mass
in the solution space
and and having having these having these
long-range correlations it's it's
essentially equivalent to this
phenomenon of having a bounded number of
questions because I'm well-liked at the
at the most extreme you could think that
your ear measure is concentrated on like
just two cubes which are small and
they're far apart in the hemming state
so in that case of course you do have
long-range correlations and here you see
some
Oh
okay so then the the predicted value of
the free energy
it's um it's given by the replica
symmetric value or the first moment
value for alpha going up to the
conversation version and it should just
be given by this s max
or
between the condensation threshold and
the the sacrificial
so in particular if you if you know the
Sigma function then you know everything
want to know about this question so then
the question is just how to calculate
Sigma and so we will calculate it by the
Legendre door so it has landed to be
take some over the the clusters will
denote CL by the side of connected
components in the solution space so
we'll just some of the clusters and take
the the size of the customer raised to
the power lambda and then if you recall
the definition of Sigma then this is the
same as summing over s so class two
sides to the power lambda will be e to
the n s lambda and then the number of
clusters that will contribute it will be
exponential of n Sigma VES as before so
this will be dominated by the point with
slope minus lambda so you can also write
this as a exponential
I know Sigma lissandra dual evaluated at
lambda and since the the Legendre
transform is in volume for combat
functions will just compute this value
and then we will recover the volume
thing so it remains to complete what
this value it
so the goal is to is to find a set of
lambda so so so how would you go about
this um so let's think about the
following thing that you can do so you
start with your original graph which is
on n variables and you can consider
reducing it to a smaller and smaller
graph so I'll define a sequence of grass
g GN minus 1 g and minus 2 etc and for
this since things are regular it's
easier to assume that alpha is integer
it doesn't really matter but so ok if
alpha is integer then what you can do is
start from your graph G so I'll go from
g2g and minus 1 by by by means of an
intermediate graph so
so dream n minus one star is the
intermediate graph and to get from here
to here I'll choose a random so I'll
choose a random vertex from g and I'll
delete it together with its step one
neighborhood this is the random variable
its neighboring clauses and also their
their neighbors and then I'll leave
behind the variables that are attached
to those classes and the remainder of
the graph is something like this and so
the remaining graph is a two star minus
lunch so this part gets deleted and then
what you have left over are these
variables which these variables here
have degree D minus one and since alpha
is integer you can form some new classes
among them to create a new regular graph
i'll call this entire set of variables w
form new classes on w so i'll call these
of you in front of new clauses just form
the causes at random and you get to a
new regular graph and then you can
repeat the operation to get too small in
flora graph and then to calculate said
you can write it as this telescoping
products so z / said n minus 1 times
and there are there are n turns in this
product and they should must be mostly
be I mean if the if a free energy exists
it's reasonable to expect that most of
these are about the same so hopefully
this is roughly 10 / said n minus 1
raise to the power
so said and / send and minus 1 you can
also write it as
this is a partition function for the
intermediate graph and likewise that i'm
inseong
at the point is to understand either of
these ratios
so let's take for example the one in the
denominator so to understand it it's
enough to know in this in this reduced
graph g star what's the Joint
Distribution of the the boundary
variable is w you don't need to know
anything more so for example we want it
for general said lambda but if you take
lambda equals 1 which is just for the
number of solutions
so this is just you sum over all the
possible assignments on these boundary
variables w and new star is the the
joint law of X sub W in the the star
graph so and minus 1x so they're dry
flaw and then just what is the new part
that you added when you went from the
start graph to the N minus 1 graph you
just added a bunch of new clauses so
product over the new classes indicator
that their neighbors are not all equal
so all you all you need to know is the
this joint distribution in the the cab
we graph and so for any lambda it's
reasonable to expect that if you have if
you have correlation decay
so this picture is not it's a bit
misleading the point is that all of the
w's are extremely far apart in the graph
because that you remove the so if you do
have correlation decay then they should
all be roughly independent from one
another and also if you have correlation
decay everybody like the neighborhood of
this guy it's it's just some some tree
and everybody has the same regular tree
that is its neighborhood so if you do
have correlation decay then they should
all be independent and they should all
be IIT they should all have the same law
so if you have correlation decay than xw
the marginal law under
under this measure new star should be
some Q which is a measure on 01 so it
should be the same queue for all of the
w's so in particular if it's a lambda
equals one it's easy to see that Q is
just the Bernoulli one-half law but for
general lambda so
okay so so also because so also because
we're on a tree so whatever the law is
here if you can think about like
removing one more layer so these are
neighboring to some more vertices so if
you removed one more layer then the
vertices below this w they should follow
the same law as before so that means
that this Q law it should also be some
functional of the the cues of the the
previous vertices meaning it should
satisfy some fixpoint equation so Q
solve some a fixpoint equation
so you can solve this fixpoint equation
and it's often the case that you have a
unique solution q star of the of the
fixpoint equation and then if you take
this cube star and just substitute it
back into into this expression and then
substitute it back into that expression
it leads to the prediction that Z will
be approximately exponential endtime
some explicit function of this Q star
okay so so if you do have such good
correlation decayed and you can you can
expect for something like this to be
true but obviously the problem is that
for the quantity that we're interested
in the number of solutions you're not
supposed to have this correlation decay
so you have to do something else and
then here there there are two there are
two main ideas so the first one it's a I
guess you can call it that you have a
replica symmetry within clusters
so ie that you have a correlation decay
not of the original measure but you
should have correlation decay of the
restricted measure new sub gamma of X
which is just the the uniform measure on
X conditioned on its belonging to a some
particular cluster so I guess this says
essentially that you have no further
complicated structure within a cluster
so why would you why would you expect
for this to be true so this is
essentially what Alan was saying that
you that you have like a forest of trees
that are a forest of trees with free
variables that are all destroying tanar
all of small size so the vast majority
of the mass vast majority of variables
are frozen so meaning that every X
within the cluster it takes on the same
value
which I guess we can denote by gamma sub
V and it either 0 or 1 so most of the
variables like 1 minus epsilon fraction
are frozen to some fixed value within
the cluster and then there's some like
small islands or free variables and you
can group them into trees such that
different trees don't interact with one
another and then what is this measure of
the distribution of X conditioned on
being in gamma so because you have all
these disjoint trees the measure
decomposes in a simple way right so nu
gamma of X is the same as first of all x
has to equal gamma on the frozen
variables so the majority of the things
are just frozen and then you have a
product measure over the the free tree
so product / free trees
some distribution of X on the the free
tree conditioned on the frozen boundary
gradually mark is that the condition
that these trees are small and over that
one is much stronger than the condition
that there is Rs within clusters yeah
yeah but that's a good point so this
this relies on this is one place where
we use that so this is like a when K is
large this condition of replica symmetry
breaking it it simplifies and you can
you can work with this sort of convert
Oriole model search for smaller okay you
don't have such
judge
so if I understand what you and Andre I
just said correctly for smaller k the
the free variables wouldn't literally be
they wouldn't literally be independent
between different components of this
forest but we would we still believe
that there is correlation decay but it
would be harder to prove yeah I think
for a small K it's not clear that the
branching process of fries will be so
like having having these like fries and
frozen zits it's sort of a cartoon of
the gift measure which is is exact for
for large values of K but Sir presumably
what's going on is that the the sub
graph of free variables percolates for
smaller k nevertheless you know for
other reasons than literal independence
between ona's we would still have
correlation decay but we're just not
sure how to prove that yes yes I I don't
know exactly for what values of K it's
made percolates I think from what I've
heard it's for k which is quite small
like Phillip 10 probably
yeah but but I mean in that case
certainly a new idea
so so in this in this large case setting
you do have this fairly simple
decomposition of the measure so here
it's obvious that you have correlation
decay because so then if you want to
know the the size the size of the the
cluster so you don't care about their
frozen variables and then you just take
the product over the free trees the the
number of solutions that are so these
sub gamma t is the number of valid
assignments valid by colorings of the
treaty which are consistent with the
frozen boundary and then so all you need
to do is calculate these quantities but
this is very easy to calculate because
it's a tree so when you have a tree this
is a free variable and maybe this is a
free variable and this is like a frozen
variable and maybe you have some further
things so this is a most naturally
calculated by by BP or it's also just by
dynamic programming so you you can
consider the effect of removing a clause
or removing a variable and it's
basically a recursive calculation that
gives you this formula and so 11 useful
way to look at it is so let's say this
is part of some larger trees so this
whole thing is some tree of free
variables if you if you were to remove
this this clause and consider the
remaining graph so these become
disconnected and then this has some
distribution in the the graph that
remain so call the the closet to you
removed call it a and call this variable
you so the the distribution of you and
the remaining graph it depends it
depends on you and it depends on a so
we'll denote this mu to a so mu tay is
the binary 0 1 and it's just a law of
you and the what remains after you
remove the egg so it's it's a
straightforward thing from from this
dynamic programming calculation that Z
gamma T it can be expressed as some
function which I guess I'll call w of
these and so this is a vector event
where for every directed edge in the
graph you consider if I remove the end
point of that edge what's the law of the
the beginning point
okay so this is also known as the BP
formula so that's one thing that that's
good and then the other thing is
the other thing is good so the first
thing is i do have replica symmetry
within the clusters and then the second
point is that you have replica symmetry
among the clusters
so again in general it's a in general
this is a broader assertion but but in
this context it's actually it's easy to
see that you you should have something
like that so so this vector m m is it's
a vector of probability measures so you
get one probability measure on zero one
for every directed for every directed
edge right and then by Bayes rule all of
these m's have to be related one to
another so whenever you have an M on a
directed edge by the israel it's some
function of the M that are in coming to
it so this has to satisfy some large
number of equations right and so as a
consequence M is it's a quite rigid
object
so if you if you have one M which is
valid for your graph and you want to
change a single em on a single edge you
have to change one that's in coming to
it and one that's coming into that and
so you have to change a huge number of
spins if you want to just change one and
we saw before that the this issue of
having long-range correlations and
replica symmetry breaking it's related
to its related to having solutions that
will group together into into some
exponential size connected components
but this this suggests that it doesn't
happen for these objects because you
don't find a year to one another so
based on this intuition it was suggested
that if you look at new tilde which is
uniform measures on BP solutions
that this this measure should have good
correlation decay just because you it's
difficult to find two M's which are
close to one another and this measure is
supposed to be the same as the uniform
measure on the clusters of the magraph
so each HBP fixed point m by this by
this discussion here each M vector
should encode encode one of the the
clusters
so you can consider the the uniform
measure but it was further suggested
that if you consider new tilde lambda so
this is a tilted version of this
measures so consider the W of em raised
to the power lambda divided by the
normalizing constant
that for a certain range of lambda this
should also be a replica symmetric
for sufficiently small lambda
but this this is exactly the the thing
that we wanted to have before so w of em
is the the size of the cluster which is
encoded by lambda and then the
denominator is exactly this set of
lambda that we wanted to compute
so if it is true that this measure is
replicas metrics and that means that
thing that I erased from this board a
few moments ago with the where you
remove a thing and put it back so for
that reason you should be able to get an
explicit formula for the limiting value
of this set of lambda so this leads to
the 1rst prediction
it leads to this explicit function f for
which set of lambda concentrates around
and then we take the legendre door to
I think that that's basically it a night
thank you any questions yeah um thanks
I'd be lovely talk hi I had one had a
minor quibble about the definition of a
replica symmetry breaking so you equate
that with correlation decay and I guess
a kind of trivial way which correlation
can fail to decay is in a ferromagnet
below the transition temperature so you
know I guess the physics answer is to
say ah that's not really what we care
about we instead we'll use submission of
connected correlation or we'll look at
the susceptibility over here to a small
field over there um is there something
there that you can do or I mean this
problem it doesn't matter revenge I
don't know yeah I guess the more
appropriate definition is that you look
at
whether it's concentrated or not right
is that what do you mean
that certainly closer what people call
it in physics but I guess I mean here
for this problem i agree with their
equivalent yeah i guess we mainly find
this to be a also their own undergoes i
get the same problem the way out is that
it should be your path to the temple to
patients right paramagnetic operations
down to see what was it important for
you that you could see what their person
in this confirmation help you see if you
would like to do it with a coefficient
soft constraint what would like down can
you repeat the question what will break
down if you move to a soft constraint
you just 82 the beta in count the number
of violations instead of four try to
find a solution
very useful to have like an exact
correlation and exact independence
between distraint
Oh
you know I was invited you don't have to
the fight
what is the technical problem if they +
in the trees of three variables
percolates and still have a very strong
vida que correlation feature you can
complete the entropy of a infinitely
large three if you know well the how the
correlation decay along the tree so what
is the technical problem if those trees
percolate yeah so in principle I think
all the estimates that are needed for
just for having this that we work with
some of the estimates many of which were
caused by human are like a torture if
you want to go to infinite version you
need to control the which we so actually
for a lower bound we didn't need to do
that
one wouldn't could
questions
all right time